in this course you will improve your
python skills by creating a snake game
using the pygame library
this course was developed by deval patel
from the popular
code basics youtube channel we will be
building
famous snake and april game using python
and pi game module
in this python project series as a
prerequisite
all you need to know is basic python
anyone can do it i am going to simplify
a lot of concepts and this will be
multiple video series so we'll go over
step by step on different pi game
concepts
and we'll build a complete game so
you're not only learning python pi game
but you're also learning
how to build a complete end-to-end
project in
python in the end i also have an
exercise for you
to work on so you can use the knowledge
that you learn in these videos and then
you can customize the game as part of
that exercise and i have the solution as
well
so this will be not just you are just
watching a video it will be interactive
learning so it will be very very useful
let's first talk about the things that
you need to install
very first thing is obvious python
installation you need to have
python installed on your computer then
you need to install a
pi game module which you can do it by
running
pep install buy game i already have it
installed so that's why it's showing
this part
you need to run this step and i use
pycharm community editor
you can just google pycharm community
download it
if you like using vs code that's okay
too
i went ahead and created this snake
underscore game directory
to store my code so you just go ahead
create some
directory and then open that directory
in pycharm
by going to file open so when i did this
it was showing me this thing now in this
directory
i have already put some useful things so
first you need
main dot pi so main dot pi the main file
it is empty right now i also have
resources folder
which will have different resources that
we will need
for our project for example it has an
image of an apple
uh some background some block image and
all that
okay you can download all this code by
looking at the
code link in the video description below
here our first objective is to
write the first program which uses
pygame and it draws a simple game window
okay so at the end of this session all
you're getting is a simple pie game
window
with some background so
let's uh let me just close
this and go into
zen mode so pyjam has this nice feature
called
enters and mode where you can
have a full screen experience okay so
here
i will say import python i'll make it a
little bigger control scroll
and then i always use
uh if underscore underscore name
is equal to underscore underscore main
this is the main routine in python okay
uh and in this routine what we're going
to do
is initiate the pygame dot
in it so so let's look at the pie game
documentation by the way
so if you look at pie game documentation
here
you can go to the pie game website look
at all the tutorials and kind of explore
it
but in this tutorial uh
whenever you're using pi game you have
to use this dot in
method it will kind of initialize that
whole
uh module okay and
once you have that next thing will be
creating a surface
so what is surface so you will say pi
game dot
display dot set mode
okay so what is set mode
so let's look at the documentation so pi
game
set mode
generally i google it okay and when you
google it you can directly go to that
so here you are saying set mode
so set mode is initializing your
game window this is the very basic step
that you have to do in
all pi game program and see the first
argument is the size of the window
how big is your window size okay so
i will say my window size is maybe what
500 by 500
this is like 500 by 500 pixel okay
and you can now say that
so let's just maybe run this program and
see what happens
see window came and it disappeared
because the program finished
so i will just maybe
put some timer so that you can actually
see you know i will put a timer for five
seconds so you at least see what's going
on
so okay my window unfortunately came in
the
in a different screen actually yeah see
you get this window 500 by 500
if you have 1000
you will get a bigger window see
so that's what this is doing now
the window background is black i want to
change it okay so you'll say surface dot
fill so this fill function
will fill the background with some color
now any color is rgb so red green blue
and these colors have values from 0 to
255 so if you want white color
you will say like 255 three times
see this did not work because whenever
you
update your surface you have to say
uh buy game
dot display dot
either update or flip
so flip is saying that whatever code you
have written here
you are just you're just
updating your screen with it so you say
control f5
now your screen is white okay
if you're not sure about which color you
want to pick up not
no rgb values so then you can do
rgb color picker so the google
google has rgb color picker so you can
decide your color
okay which color do you want
maybe i want this color as a background
what is rgb
92 2584
you put that here and see you get this
color
so getting that color is is not a big
deal so i'm just going to
use some color you can use a different
color up to you
okay all right so now your window is set
up next thing i want to do
is see i i had to use
timer which is something i don't like i
want to do something where
the window stays and when i hit escape
or cancel then only window disappears
so i'm going to remove this sleep
statement
so how do you do that so in any ui
application
you have a thing called event loop
event loop is waiting for the user input
when you are
working on any screen it is waiting for
mouse input or keyboard input
so you have to run that event loop event
loop
is fundamental to any ui programming it
doesn't matter pie game any ui
you take you need to have an event loop
an event loop will be
something like it's a while loop
so you will say okay running is false
or maybe running is true actually so
running is true and
while running
do something so now see this is an
infinite loop
we need to exit it somewhere right but
the fundamentals of ui programming is
you are running this infinite loop but
on certain keystrokes such as if you hit
a cancel
or escape you want to exit your game
so how do you do that well pi game has
this thing called event so
pygame dot event dot
get so
for event in pygame.even
get
do something so what is this
well this will give you all the keyboard
mouse
all kind of events okay and you can read
the documentation online
but this events will have type so if
event
dot type is equal to what
for that i need to import certain local
so i will say import
pi game dot locals
uh from i will just do this
import star so this is going to
import certain global variables which
will be useful to us
such as key down
see this key down this one came
from this okay
so if you want to read more about it you
can just say
buy game
locals and that will
tell you all the locals right so
[Music]
event so for event you will have
different locals
and so see for event these are the event
sites so p
down is something we use there is
another event called quit
which will be called when you hit the
cancel window
so i will say okay if even dot type is
key down then do something lf
event.type is equal to
quit okay
then okay so if user clicks on cancel
what do you want to do
well you just set your running variable
to false
you might have read about while loop
before or if you have followed my python
tutorials you know about while loop
while loop is like it goes
in iteration until this condition is
true
so running is true all the time except
when we have a quit event okay so let's
try this
so quit event is generated when
when you click on cancel see now your
program exited
otherwise your pro that window will not
exit okay
also let's say i want to quit when i hit
escape key so you can say if
event dot key
if event dot e is equal to
escape
then also running is false
so when i run it now and see i'm not
using mouse
i'm hitting escape key and my program
exited okay so this understanding of
this whole event loop
in pi game is very essential and it will
be useful
when you're doing ui programming with
any language any framework
all right so far
it is looking good now the next step
i have some reference content here so
that i can do my videos properly
so the next thing i want to do is
i want to draw a block okay so that
block you saw here
so i have this block here so this image
i want to just draw on my screen
somewhere all right so how do you do
that
well for that you need to
load that image uh and the way you load
that image
is by doing this
so pygame has this image module you can
just say load
and resources block.image and dot
convert this is a method of
loading the image and once you have the
image
in this block variable you can
see let's look at load documentation
see this is the load documentation okay
and block
you can uh paint on a surface so your
background screen is this surface
we will say surface you know surface is
your background
your main window on that if you you want
to draw a block
so for that there is a function called
blit
so this blade function is nothing but
draw this image and what do you want to
draw well block where do you want to
draw
these are the dimensions so
maybe 100 hundred
you see 100 is drawing here if you do 0
0 this is x and y so if you do 0 0
it will draw at the very left so this is
x and y
okay so i will just assign
some variable for the dimension so i
will say block
x is 100 let's say and block
y is also 100
okay and then
block x block y
all right now next thing i want to do
is i want to move this block okay
so when i move this block using my
maybe key like one of the common things
in any game is using the up
down left right keys okay when i
press those keys i want to move the
block around
so how do i do that well first let me
write a function which draws
this block so i'm going to write a
python function which is drawing the
block
okay so it's the same code see this
code i have just put it in a function
so i put one two
and three these three lines
into a function so when i call that
function
it will just draw a block so now
how do i move that block all right so
let's think about that
so here we are getting this event site
so
if event dot key
is equal to let's say up
see when you press up key what you're
doing is
your block is at a position x okay
so let me just draw it so that you
understand
so when you are let's say this is your
screen
okay on this screen you have a block so
this is your block
and block is at the position x comma y
so it's a it's a coordinate system
x and y okay
so let's say this x is 100 right now
so x is 100 and y is also 100 okay
so when you move up key the y
remains the x remains same but you're
changing your y
your y is 100 and now you are moving it
up so maybe you're changing it
by some amount when you move it down
again you're changing y but when you
move this block
see when you have this block and when
you move it like this
your x remains same because x is this
but you are no your y remains same
but your x will change so see your y
so this y is this axis
okay and this x is this particular axis
you might have learned about basic
coordinate system
in your mathematics class so it is this
x
so when you have left and right movement
you are
playing with x up and down movement you
are playing with y
so when your key is up what i want to do
is
whatever y i have maybe i want to
subtract
10 from y this is same as doing this
okay they both are same
and when you have let's say
down you want to increment
y by 10 and if you have
let's say left when you press on a left
key
you want to update your
x actually
and if your
event key is
this is all probably very easy to
understand
you're just changing your coordinate now
when you're having up key you're not
changing your
x because x remains the same and when
that happens you are just
after after changing your coordinate you
are calling draw block function
because draw block needs to draw it now
let's look at draw block function
so in draw block function by the way
when you are moving drop
your block up and down uh let me comment
this line i'll tell you why that
line is needed let's first do it without
that line
so you're uploading block x and y
and using that you are drawing that
block again and you have to call this
flip method
otherwise it will not show you what
you've done right
you can also call update method
okay so i'm just calling there is some
minor difference you can read about that
online so if i do
ctrl f5 now see when i'm pressing
right key it's moving right and when i'm
pressing
down it's moving down and then moving
left
but the previous block are still there
i don't want those blocks when i move
the block block should just move
and for that reason you need this line
so before drawing
the block you are clearing your screen
so when you have this line now see
you do up left right
whatever and block moves smoothly
congress you have a very first basic buy
game program working for you
you did an awesome job when i'm i'm
teaching you on video tutorials
make sure you have your code editor open
and you do coding along with me
because that will give you effective
learning in the
next session we'll continue with this
but in this session
i have only this much you just build a
screen and a block which can move around
all right
so far our code looks good but
the code is not very readable so in this
session
we are going to make it object-oriented
programming so there is a thing called
object-oriented programming or
oops so we are going to make it such
that it
follows the oops principle which is
basically
converting this into classes and objects
so let's get started here
you see a huge block of code in your
main function itself
usually when you're working on proper
python projects
you don't rather write so much code in
your main entry point
so you would have things like all right
what if i have
a class called game okay
and this is how you define class if you
don't know about classes and objects you
can follow my
python video on classes and objects and
you will get an understanding that's
like a prerequisite
here this is a constructor so we'll
write constructor
but what if in my main method
here i have only two line of code
and that code will be you create an
object of a game
and you just say dot run okay
and here of course you will have a run
function
and we'll implement all these functions
but this is my idea
i want to have only two line of code in
my main method
and everything else should be classes
and objects
all right so let's start moving
all of this code into your classes
so the pie game in it of course
this will go into your game
initialization
then the next thing you have
is a surface so this surface will
also go into your game initialization
and i will make this surface a class
member and when you do self.something
you're making that a class member so
that
later on the surface is available here
as well okay so that's the idea
all right so we moved that
okay we have block which we will look
into
little later but let's see if there is
anything else
nope that's it all right so so far
game looks good now the block
is something we are building to build
our snake
ultimately so then
how about we build a class called snake
okay and that class
this class will have that block object
so let me move all this here
so again i will just say self.block
and then um
self.x is hundreds of dot y is hundred
all right so this way i get rid of
that that code so see you now kind of
get a get a feel of this process where
you have
written some experimental code and when
it works
you want to convert it into a object
oriented code
and this is how you do it all right
now when you see this is like drawing
the block
so i want to draw the block so in my
snake method maybe i can
add draw function you know
so when you say snakesnake.draw it will
just draw that snake
so right now a snake is just one block
okay
here i need a parent surface
but i don't have that so generally when
you're doing class programming
you want to pass that surface as an
argument into this function
or the other option you have is
you store it as a class member so i'm
just going to call that surface a parent
screen
and i will store it in a new class
member called parent screen
okay and when i draw it
i will say self dot apparent screen dot
blit and this block has to be self dot
block
and this x and y has to be self.x
self.y all right
okay so
now you know this game
see this game is kind of the main object
and game is having
a snake inside it so you have a game
game has a snake
so for that for that reason i will
create a snake
inside my game class
so i created a snake inside my game
class
now snake constructor expects parent
screen
so what is my parent screen self dot
surface
okay and once that is done
i want to draw the snake
all right so this looks good so far
so by the way when you draw this you're
drawing this
so you're kind of replacing this
so that draw function is exactly this
draw
so there were two more things that we
wanted to do
which is fill and
see this this line will come in the
middle okay
and this will be self dot surface dot
fill
and this will be pi game dot display
so when you have snake and when you say
snake dot draw
it will draw the snake or a block on the
surface so now we remove this function
as well
okay what is left now
okay a main event loop is left so this
main event loop
i will copy this in a run function
okay because that run function is kind
of the main function
so we are running the event let's look
at it
okay here i don't have access of block x
and draw block etc right
so what do we do but we have access of
snake object
so so snake all right so let's do this
so when you click when you do left click
you want to move the snake
to left so what if we have a function
called move left
so that i don't have to worry about all
this
when you say move left it should move
left
when you press right key it should move
right
releasing this will be amazing it will
make code so
much readable
so move right i'm just typing these
methods
they don't exist but i am going to write
them
this is how you do object
oriented programming move down
okay so i
need to write all these methods in my
snake class now so let's write
that method to move left
okay what do you do when you move left
we saw in a previous session moving left
means you are just changing a position
of
x because your y is same so i will just
do
self dot x -10
you know subtract 10 pixels from your x
so that
your block moves on the left hand side
once it is subtracted
you want to draw it and for drawing
there is a method so you can see your
code is becoming more readable
it kind of makes sense in your brain
right moving left is
subtracting by 10 and then drawing it
previously
code was little cryptic and similarly
you can uh
you can maybe implement the rest of the
method see move right move up and down
okay so it's very very easy very easy to
understand now
so when you read your code see you're
starting your
to your python program first you're
creating game
game says run okay what does run do
run is running your event loop in the
event loop you are having snake you're
moving left and right
so code is more readable now and when
you right click and run this
okay snake object doesn't have an
attribute self dot surface
yeah it doesn't have self-drive so it
has self the parent screen actually
so i'm pressing left and right
and the block is moving i did not make
any functionality change but in this
session
we did an amazing thing which is
converted a programming to object
oriented programming
this is needed if you want to become a
good
programmer a good programmer can
program write object oriented
programming method
and the code is readable maintainable
you know when you work for big companies
the code bases are very big
so when new person joins already there
are million lines
so if code is readable like see right
now code is more readable
then it helps so oops or object oriented
programming concepts
makes you a better programmer that's why
that's why i think
this session is very very important so i
hope you all learned all these lessons
till now we are moving this block
manually using
left and right keys in this session i
want to move this block automatically
you might have seen games where blocks
are falling
planes are flying you don't know
anything and they keep on moving
so i will do the same thing with this
block so that
if i'm not touching any key and if it's
going down it keeps on going down
when i touch right key let's say it will
just change the direction
but it will just keep on moving on its
own
so for that what i need to do here
is introduce a timer
seen this while loop this code is
handling all key events
but outside this block you know
like here i need to
maybe put a timer so here
i will put some timer and on that event
so let's say i have some method called
for dot uh
so if i have a method called self dot
snake dot
walk so snake i have right
so that's hypothetium we don't have this
method but just hypothetically think
that on this method snake walks on its
own without you placing a key
now this rule loop is running very fast
so if you do this snake will move really
really fast so you need to introduce
some
delay and you can use
time module for that
so we'll introduce some sleep time so
here
we'll say time to sleep
let's say point two second
so every two sec point two second it
moves on its own
point two second moves point two second
moves and
in this walk function we need to
implement here so let me just implement
block function here
so walk okay what do we do in walk
well of course in walk function now you
will be
drawing uh the snake and
based on the direction based on the
current direction
at given point of time snake could be
moving left right
top bottom so based on the direction
you need to increase the x and y
coordinates okay
so we need to have this direction
parameter which i'll add here
so self dot direction let's say
initially
you're making a direction up or down
it could be anything i'm just randomly
selecting
and based on that direction so let me do
this so
if self.direction is up
so if it is up what do you do well we
saw previously that
if it is up you only reduce yc
we are reducing y and
if the direction is
let me just copy paste just to save some
time here
if it is right of course you are more
manipulating only x
if it is up y and so on
this is something we already went
through when we are looking at this
function
and you draw it so now what will happen
is
even if you're not press your any key in
your while loop based on a direction
snake will keep on moving on its own
now what happens when you press any key
let's say if you press
left key you call move left which is
fine
but on this move left you don't want to
change anything you want to change
only the direction okay
so i will say move left my direction
is left if it is move right
my direction is right
move up
direction up move down
direction down looks good i think
now let me try it so just to go world
on while loop when you call this
function you are just changing a
direction
and even if you have not press any key
on walk function
based on the direction you are moving
the snake
so say i'm not pressing any key now
using my hands
and block is moving when i press right
key just change the direction
up key change the direction left key
chain the direction
all right looks great it already looks
like a game don't you think so
in moving blocks games this is what they
do
so congratulations you just implemented
a nice version of a little small stupid
game
uh in the next video
or in the next session we will convert
this
block into a full-fledged snake
in this session we will be building a
snake out of a block
see right now the there is only one
block it is moving on its own
uh this is actually a snake with length
one
if i put let's say five six
blocks let's say if i put six blocks
then this becomes
a snake so we'll introduce a length
parameter
in our snake class and if let's say
length is
5 then it will look like this so instead
of one block we have five blocks
so the first thing i'm going to do now
is
enter my zen mode you know i'm doing a
meditation
the snack and apple meditation so here
i will introduce a parameter of length
lngth so self
dot land is equal to length
and now i don't have a one x and y
because when you have a snake with size
five
essentially you have five x and y c one
x and y is nothing but a left top
coordinate of
a block so if your five blocks
you should have five x and y and how do
you do that
well in python this is easy
you can do something like
length okay so this will initialize an
empty array
of size length if you want to verify it
what i do usually is i go to python
console
so exit the same mode i go to python
console here
and if you do something like let's say
this file
oh this is not working okay i need to
given um
some value so let's say if i do 67
see if i do five it's creating an array
of five
if i do three it will create an array of
three elements
so that's exactly i do this python
console is a useful feature you can use
it
so now i will just
initialize it with size 40 so by the way
i will just
create a variable call
size is equal to 40 and this size is
nothing but the size of a block actually
the actual length of the snake is this
length
and see if you look at my block
dot jpg right this is the image we are
using
if you look look at the dimension of it
it is 40 by 40.
so that's why uh i want to
put initial position to be
let's say 40 40 it could be 80 it could
be 120
and then um i want to
just implement my move logic now before
i implement
my move logic i need to
change the draw function because draw
function
is just drawing 1 x and y now we have
multiple x and y
so instead of this i will have a poor
look and i will say
you know go till the length and
do
draw x and y basically okay
now initially i initialized
my entire array let's say if you have a
snake length of two so let's do that
so here when you create your snake
let's say i have a size little bit two
you would ask me why do you have bought
the blocks at same position
ideally you should have it at different
position
but my move logic will take care of it
it will unwrap my snake you know as i
move
so how would i change my move logic then
well before i do anything let me just
run it just for the sake of it
oh yeah it's not working because when
you walk you are changing this
x and this x is an array now
okay so we have to implement this walk
function okay how does
walk work well let's see
so when you have a snake like this okay
and let's see if i move it in a right
direction
i put a right key what's happening is
let me mark this line see this is my
head
right this particular block when i move
it to right
the block will move to right okay so my
block move to right
perfect the logic for this
is what we saw already if you're moving
right
increase x by some amount moving up
increase y by some amount
but what do you do with this other
blocks well
my second block comes at the position of
my
first block my third block
comes at the position of my second block
and so on
so every block is taking a position of
its previous block
now writing this logic becomes very easy
because
here when you are changing a direction
of course the logic remains same for
the first block which is your head of
the snake
okay so this remains same but we have
more blocks
so for those blocks you need to put them
at the position of previous block so how
do you do that well you have to run
a or loop in a reverse direction so you
start with the last block
so fifth block you put at fourth fourth
you
put at three and in order to do that
you can just do this self.length minus
one
okay go all the way till
uh zero
in a range by the way it will not
consider zero so actually you are going
till one
and minus one is a step size so step
size means you are going in a reverse
so this for loop is nothing but going in
a reverse direction you start with
5 4 3 2 and so on
and the current x position
will be your previous block's position
okay and you do the same thing with your
y
all right let's see
see now actually it's a snake with two
blocks but see the
the distance between the blocks is very
minimal
it's it's like 10 pixel so i need to
make it
size which is a 40 so that you know
the size of block is 40 so you want to
keep them 40 pixel
apart
so yes i size size size sizes
great see i move it up
let down my screen now is a little
smaller so i want to increase the size
here to let's say thousand eight hundred
and also
that just increasing the timer so that
is not moving
very fast see so this is how the
snake with length 2 looks like if you
have
let's snake with length 6.
this is how it looks like see when i
move left up
down etc
now that my snake is kind of ready i
want to now draw
apple so for apple
so the purpose of the game is snack is
eating an apple
apple goes at random position and as
snake eats apple
the length of the snake will increase
if you are not sure about this i have
all the source code in the video
description below
so just take the final version of the
source code and try to run and play the
game so you get an idea
so here now i need to create
an apple class so see in object oriented
programming
whatever objects you have you create
classes for those objects so we have
snake we have apple
so we created classes for both of it
now apple is also an image
so if you look at this image this is
also 40 by 40 pixel image
so i need to load that image first right
and we have already seen how you load
the image
like the same code i just copy paste it
here
and people also needs a
parent screen here see how you have a
parent screen i'm just going to change
this
we need a parent screen so that apple
can be
painted on that parent screen
okay and what else do we need
yeah x and y because apple has a
position
right and this position will also be in
the multiple of 40
so i'm gonna keep it 120 so like 120 by
120
see if i put it 20 then snake and april
will not align it has to be multiple of
40. so just to make it generic
you can do something like this also
and of course you need our draw function
to draw the apple
and how does it draw work well it will
be i can just
copy paste this code
so there is no for loop of course
so here instead of solves that lot i'm
just saying self.image
and x and y i'm painting here
i probably don't need fill here because
fill i will do it in a
snake draw function okay
all right so now i have my apple
here now apple i need to initialize in
my game class okay
how i initialize snake so i will just
say
this is my apple and the
parent screen you need to pass and then
you need to say
draw now when you are running
this event loop see here you are saying
self.snake.work so here also you need to
draw your apple otherwise what happens
is in the walk function
you are uh in a draw function you are
clearing the screen so it will
clear the apple so that's why we need to
do this
so see ice i see the apple now
which is good um
okay now one thing i noticed was
right now i have two objects if you have
like four or five ten objects
and you have to keep on doing things as
object.draw
so just to modularize my code
i will write a method called play in my
game class
and this method play
will have those two methods
and then it's just working the same but
at least
code wise when you read it it's like
in your full loop okay in your while
loop play
and play is doing all the drawing
okay
so far we are moving over snake
and there is an apple but there is no
actual game logic which is if
snake eats the apple it should increase
the length
and then april should move to a
different position so in this video we
are going to
implement that logic now collision
detection is a very common thing in
any of any video game
so we are going to implement that
concept so
first we will write a function
in our game okay so what do we want to
do just think about it
when snake's head hits
the apple we want to increase the score
so how do you detect that so just just
think about it so
let me open uh paint and kind of
go over that a little bit so let's say
your this is your
application screen and
let's say this is your name
this is your snake right so it's just uh
like a couple of blocks i'm just going
to make it bigger
and it is just uh
list of blocks nothing else right okay
so
let's say this is my snake
and let's say this is my apple
now the apple also has a bounding box
so apple is actually a circle it's an
icon that you're showing so it will be
like this
and when you hit that apple
what's happening is let's say this snake
comes here for example this guy here
let's say comes into this area let's see
this is collision
right so here what happened is
actually the the y
the x of both of these are same the
snake is moving up
but what has changed is the y
so just think about why so this is
your y correct y one let's say
this is for apple and
this is your y
two for your head of the snake right so
this is the axis that i'm referring to
and for y one this is the point that
we're referring to
now what happens is when they collide
see y one plus size is what so y1 plus
size will be this much see y1
plus size is basically this much size is
the height of the
apple so now what happens is y2b
y2 is in that boundary it is in y1
plus psi so if you do let's say y1
plus size this y2 now is in that
boundary
you got it so my y2
is now less than y1 plus size so this is
how you can detect
the vertical collision same thing with
x okay so we are going to implement
that method as per that logic which i
just explained
so in the collision always you're trying
to decide if two
rectangles are colliding so then you
will always have x1 y1
x2 y2 okay
and if x1
is less than equal to x1 plus size
see the width and height of both
apple as well as the snake block
is 40 so that's what we have initialized
size to be 40.
so
x1 is less than that and
actually x1 is uh so the logic will be
x1
is greater than equal to
x2
let's think about y first okay so
why here your y2 is less than
y1 plus size
okay so similar logic you can apply for
x1 as well so x1 is greater than
equal to x2 and x1
is less than equal to x2
plus size and the same
logic applies for y1 and i'll go to the
diagram and explain you in a bit
but if
the same logic for y if both of these
conditions are true
then you return true saying that there
is a collision this means there is a
collision
otherwise there is not according okay
so let's let's understand this y1
greater than equal to y2 and y1
less than equal to y2 plus size okay
so here
so here this is being my y one so let me
just uh here in my code at least
see i have this as y2
and this as y1
so what's happening is see let's look at
this logic here
so that logic will go here this is the
logic we have
right what this means is let me just put
it in a bigger window
what this means is uh my y1
is less than y2 plus psi so we you
already saw this y1
okay is less than of
y2 plus size
okay and ah
your y1 is greater than equal to y2 so
y1 is greater than equal to y2
okay so you can just debug the code and
kind of
figure out what it means here actually
hold on y 1 is greater than equal to y
1 is actually less than so i think
previously what i was doing
is correct which is
see it can be either way like so i think
this is y1
and this is y2 okay
this is white and this is y1 plus size
so if you look at this let's say if you
think about this as a y axis so y axis
starts from zero first right
so it will be zero here
then it will be whatever
like maybe 5 here
and 20 and so on so it is increasing in
this direction
so if you think from that perspective
the y1 is greater than equal to y2
right so this condition is met and y1
is less than equal to y 2 plus psi so if
you have y 2 here
and if you do y 2 plus size which is 4 t
so this block so y 2 plus psi so y 2
plus size is this much right
so y y1 is less than that that's why
this collision logic works
so just debug it you figure it out this
is a simple logic
now when snake
hits uh the apple you want to increase
the length
okay so here in the
play section if self dot is collision
okay and you you want to check the
impact with only snakes head actually
because you don't need to check it with
the body
so snake's head is the position
zero and then
you will say this apple
dot y so checking the coordinate of
apple and snake's head which is at
element number zero
and if you find a collision you will say
this print collision
occur right now just do let's do this
much
uh just to make sure things are working
okay
and
uh after that
let's see if we have anything pending so
you're doing collision
okay let's run it
so you see that
you see this collision occurred message
right
so that means the collision happened and
now
we can whenever collision happens what
we want to do is
we want to move the apple to a different
position
different random position so let's write
the code for that
so we'll say apple
dot move so this means
once snake apple hits the apple
we move apple to a random position and
for that you can come to this class
here apple and write this method called
move
so here you will move uh
this two to a random position okay
now how do you do that so there is a
model called
random which you can import here and
i'll show you see if you do
idle uh i'll just quickly show you how
random works so
random has this function called rand end
so if you
give lesson 1 and 10 it will give you a
random number between 1 and 10. see
every time you run it gives number
between 1 and 10.
now our window is
thousand thousand by 800 correct
and apple's size is 40.
so if you do little calculation
thousand okay divided by 40
you get like 25 increments
and if you do 800 divided by 40
you get 20 so you get like this
horizontally 25 increment of 40
and vertically 20 increment of 40. so
what i can do is
here i can say random dot random okay
give me a number between 0 and 25 so
horizontally i have 25
increment into size
so what will happen here is if you look
at idle
let's say between you know like 1 and 25
i'll just do one because
or 0 is also fine and size is 40.
so see every time it gives me a number
which is always gonna be less than
thousand so we don't go out of our
window boundary
and the number will be divided by 14.
it will be a multiple of 40
and i did the same thing with pi so for
y with 800 height you can get 20
increments okay
so you after the collision you move it
so let's run this
see after i'm colliding
so my collision detection is happening
perfectly
okay and the snake is moving
okay now on collision you want to
increase the size of the snake so that
will be a score
so in the initial phase i will
maybe i'll start with the snake size of
10 2
or maybe one and then
i just keep on incrementing the length
okay so on collision
you want to increment the length so here
okay where is my collision yeah here you
want to say
length you want to increment right but
you have to do something else as well
which is
when you increment your length see
you need to add one more block in this x
and y
because x and y is an array
it is holding the position of the new
block
so for that reason i will just write a
new method here
called increase length
okay where you first of course you first
increase the length but then
you want to add something into x and y
so this is how you add a new element
into an
array and i'm adding -1 as a value you
can always
tackle this in your walk function in
your work function
we'll put a right coordinates
of x and y that's why we can just start
with some random value here
so here
i will say increase length
and let's run this
see now after it hit it it the size of
snake is 2
now see it is 2 and if i hit it again it
will become 3
you will watch it
deny it become 4.
pi and so on okay
i think i noticed something weird
ah see if it moves even near
near say i'm not going through apple if
i go even above
apple this is fine
if i'm going even from near apple it is
increasing the weight and i think that's
because of this less than equal
i think this should be probably less
than
see now it's working as expected so now
it increase the length
and so on so here also apple moved to a
very far position so i want to restrict
it
so i'll just say 40 this is 90
on 0 0 position is probably okay
all right so this is looking pretty good
so now next thing i want to do is
display the score
okay so in my game function i will write
a method called displace code
and this should just display the score
at the maybe top right
you know i will choose top right to dis
for displaying the score
and pi game has this font
module so i'm using the system font
which is area
with the 30 font size you can increase
it as well
and then uh this font i will store
into a variable called score so this is
how you do it
and here the score is nothing but the
snake's length
okay so i'm using python format string
storing it uh storing the score there
and in render function this is uh your
color so if you do like 255 to 55 255 it
will be white color
so you can choose whatever color you
like and then
you know we always have a surface so
whenever you want to show anything on
the surface you have to use
blit function and then
what are the coordinates well let's say
810 so that there will be top right
corner
and once you do that here
i can display the score
and after displaying score of course you
have to do
buy game dot display dot flip
so you see the score at the top here
okay
so now ah
c score increase two score is equal to
the length of my snakes three zero i'm
doing good
wonderful my game is coming up so nice
guys
so in last session we calculated the
score
by finding out the collision between a
snake
and an apple in this session we will
work on a game over logic which is if
the snake
is curling around and if it hits its own
body
then the game is over so for that again
we are going to use this
is collision function right so here
let me just run it and tell you what
exactly i'm trying to do
so here let's say you have a snake of
size
seven when you run it
ah see if you get into this situation
you see like when snake is crossing
itself then we want to exit the game
so this was a logic of snake
colliding with apple now we are writing
a logic of snake oh
gliding with and for that
you know snake has a number of blocks
right so you can just do for i
in range 0 to self
dot length
now what type of collision you're trying
to find well
you want to find out if the head of the
snake which is
x0 collides with itself or not so if you
look at
whatever this diagram that we have let
me just
clean it all
so here let's say this is my snake
okay and let's say it's moving moving
moving
and it makes a ton like this and it
makes it turn like this
and then it again goes here then that's
collision so then that's when you should
die
so this guy is the head so you want to
find a collision of head with remaining
blocks
so you will say if self
dot is collision okay position of what
self dot snake dot x sub zero
set dot snake of y zero because x zero
and y zero is ahead
with remaining blocks
so x of i
and
y of y now since we are finding a
collision with
x0 we can start with one okay
now let's think about it even
we can optimize later later so this
head of the snake will never collide
with the next
part you agree no matter what happens
it will never ever collide with this
and i think same thing will happen with
the third block can it collide with
third block no
so 0 1 2 so maybe you can start with 3
directly
so here we can start with 3
and if there is a college collision
for now let's say you want to exit the
game
you'll say game over and exit it
okay
okay i don't know what happened it went
out of the boundary
see when it when it hit itself
it it is exiting
with that game over
message so logic wise is working fine
but what i want to do is when that thing
happens
i want to show a nice message saying
that the game is over
and um also if they want to replay
then we should give some them some
option of replaying let's say
if game is over if they hit enter then
we want to
uh give them that option okay
so first of all i'll remove this
and instead of that i will raise an
exception see exception means
so exception raising exception means
something unusual happen and you want to
go out of the game
and you're throwing an exception and
here you have to catch that acceptance
and this is how you do it if you don't
know about this
again follow my basic python videos
and you will get an idea on this
exception and here all right
what do you want to do here i want to
maybe show a game over
message okay and that
game over message uh
let's see what do we want to do
so in the game over message here
show game over here in this method
i want to display a nice text in the
middle
saying that the game is over uh and
for that first you need to clear clear
the surface right
because uh whatever you have you want to
wipe out you just show a message
so here for fill which color did we use
well we use this i'm going to store
this in a variable called background
color
okay so background color is equal to
this
and i will see whenever in programming
language when you are using
something more than multiple time more
than one time
it's better you create a variable
okay and once the screen is wiped out
now you can
render your text so but that will use
the
this thing like font your lead we
already show the
score so we can use the same thing here
and okay so i'll say line one spawn dot
render something
so what is our score so we want to show
the score to a user and then
we want to exit the game so you see
score this one
so i'm just copy pasting the same thing
and i'm showing it in white color you
can change this this color this is rgb
and self dot surface dot grid and
anytime you want to show anything
on a surface this is what you call and
i am showing an x and y's is 200 200 300
which is in the middle of the screen
i want to also show another message
saying that to play the game again
you can hit enter maybe
and i will just show line two
and 350 name
okay so show game over let's see what
happens
okay something is not right so show game
ever is here
okay so let's
turn
so i realized this was happening because
i did not have flip
in the shoe gaming work so whenever you
are making any ui changes you
have to call pygame.display.flip so ui
is ref
this is like refreshing your ui
so now
see so game over message is showing up
but then it's again restarting the
message
i restarting the the the game and why is
that happening
well that is happening because
just think about it you show this
message okay
after that you wait point two second
you're again going into this loop
see again processing all those
keystrokes
so we have to
implement a pause mechanism here
so we'll say okay pause is false
and when the game is over
pause becomes true and when the game is
paused by the way
i don't want to uh process
all of this right so game is paused here
yeah if the game is paused i don't want
to process even left right all these
keystrokes
or yeah this one if not pause
i don't play the game if if it is paused
correct so this is something you don't
want to do
also okay let's let's run just this and
see what happens
the game is over now now i hit anything
and it's not
go it's not restarting so we said to
play again press enter so if you
press enter you want to unpause it so
how do you do that
well here
you can say if event dot key
is equal to k enter is basically return
and here you will say pause is true
okay so
pause is false actually
so here okay game exited
okay i'm pressing keys nothing is
happening
and when i hit enter
say game started again also just to make
it safe
you don't want to process even left
right keys if the game is pauses pause
guys
you don't want to do anything so don't
process all these
keystrokes if the game is paused simple
enough
all right now let's see what's remaining
so after the game is paused
see my score is right now let's say
eight
nine score and game exits my score is
nine
if i hit escape i go out but i want to
play this game again so when i hit enter
see it is starting with score 9 again
so that is bad because you are not
resetting the game
so here you need to reset the game so
you will call self-loath reset method
and reset method is something you will
implement here so you will say reset
okay how do you reset the game well
whatever
snake and apple you have you just
reinitialize those two
and i'll initialize it with one okay
so when the i have scored seven
and when the game is over when i hit
enter
see i start fresh with score one
okay so i think you get an idea and by
the way
i don't want to start with like score
seven in the beginning as well
so here also i do want so that way you
know you always start with one block
then it increases ah my apple moved out
see my apple is moving out
where is it yeah this is happening
because
we have we need to reduce this limit
maybe
yeah because it's probably moving too
fast so that's why i'm
reducing the limit and i hope
it works now yeah
so far our project is working fine it is
functionally correct
but it doesn't look very fancy because
it doesn't have any music
the background is dull so in this uh
session we are going to add
background music as well as the
background texture or to
this game for this what we'll do is
whenever snake is eating an apple will
play some music
like ding or something when the snake
collides with itself we'll play another
music
and then in the background also we'll
keep on playing some music so first
let's take a snack eating apple scenario
so you need a short music clip first of
all
so for that i did some google found this
nice website pre-sounds library
which has this ding sound so see if you
play this link sound
see chin so we'll play that
when snake it apple so in the resources
directory i downloaded that file
so say ding.mp3
and for collision crash
so when it collides with this we will
play this music okay
now when you do google on pi game pi
game play sound
you will find this class in pi game
called mixture
which has a sound element to it okay
so we'll be using pi game mixture for
playing music
and in that you first need to do pygame
dot mixture dot in it so let's do that
it will initialize the mixture model
so let me just first go into my
meditative zen mode
all right so no distraction now you go
away buddy
all right so here in the init
i will say
pygame dot mixture dot in it so
my sound module is initialized
now when i have a collision
or let's say
yeah when i sneak eat apple
i want to play the music so how do you
play that so you will just say simply
by game dot mixture dot sound
okay and in the sound you will
use resources i will use ding music
and let's store this in a variable
called sound
and then you can just say pie game dot
mixture dot
sound dot play so that
plays the sound
so i'll right click run it
see when snake hits apple it will play
the music c
listen carefully see
ding okay and when it collides
you'll be playing the crash music so
here
i'll just say crash
so let's taste that as well
putting guys working okay
see your game is over your score is
three
so that sound that you just saw now
whenever in your big program
you find that you are repeating the
lines of code
it's better to put them in a function
here
between these two line and these two
line the only difference is this
name of the sound so what i can do is i
can put
these two into a function
called play sound let's say you know
and we can supply the name of the sound
as well actually
so here see here i can do self
dot play sound but i need to tell this
function that it needs to play ding
so i will just say ding here which i can
get that
as an input sound and here
i can maybe convert it to python format
string
and here if you have sound variable so
whatever you pass here it will
try to load that dot mp3 file
so here in this case it will be crash
okay and
now tomorrow if you want to play 10 more
sounds you just call that function with
the
name of the file if you don't want to
use name of the file then you can just
check here like if
sound is equal to ding then that's your
file okay
all right so you can run it it will work
okay
now i want to play background music as
well while the game is being played you
know you want to hear nice music
so i have downloaded this background
music from
youtube audio library
so that music i will play in the
background so again i will define a
function called
play background music here
in here i will be playing that music so
now this time instead of sound
i will use music so
the difference between the music and
sound is that
sound is just one time like dingo crash
music is like a long music
which you use generally as a background
music
and resources
okay and then buy
game dot make sure music dot play
so that will play the music and you want
to call this function
when the game starts right there itself
you want to start playing the music okay
so
okay initially there was one or two
second pause because the game itself the
music itself has a pause
okay now once this is done
what you want to do is see when the
the game pauses for example when you
hit like when you hit snake
body okay
you want to stop the music
[Music]
so let me show you what i mean
[Music]
see music is still playing i want to
stop music
and when you restart then maybe start
the music so
when you have game over scenario here
game over right here during this time
maybe i can call pygame dot
mixture dot music dot pause so
it has a nice method called pause so it
will just pause the background music
okay
and uh you want to resume it when user
hits enter
so when this is when you are unpausing
it so here you can say
pygame dot make sure dot music dot
on pause okay and now it will
pause and pause easily
[Music]
the music stop now and
when you start again it will
uh restart the music again
now i want to change the background of
our game so for that i have downloaded
this nice texture
so this looks like you know grass field
on which snake is moving around
so i will set this as a background in
our
game so for this purpose i will here
define a new function called render
background
you know and
you know like like image you can load
easily by calling pygame dot
image dot load and here
you can load this background image
and if you want to show this image you
know that that
you have to use this blit function okay
so
try game dot
actually sell
where you specify where you want to draw
the image on your surface
and x and y so we want to render this
background from
zero zero corner all the way right
now this background size is actually you
see 1920 by 1080
and our window size is thousand by 800
so it will
work okay now this render background
i will do why should i
call this function you know what we are
doing this background color
so wherever we are calling this function
you have to
replace that with rendered background so
here
self dot
okay now this is weight so this is
different class actually
so here you're drawing it right so
you're drawing snakes so where do i
where do i draw snake here
here yes here so here
i have to say render background
because you draw apple and everything so
just before that you have to render the
background
okay where else did we use oh show game
over so here also self dot
render background
so now see nice background you know it
looks
looks pretty good so you can play with
the background
the apple image the score fonts and make
your game little
more fancy the code for this entire
project is available here i have python
projects directory where i will be
uploading more python projects so please
keep an eye
right now it's just one project snake
game and if you go to that project
by clicking here by the way my next
project is gonna be document text
extension using ocr and there'll be
different projects that i'll be covering
but for this project i have an exercise
for you
so if you scroll down
the exercise is whenever snake hits the
left or right or bottom boundary or top
boundary
you want to exit the game okay so game
should remain in the field
if it goes out of the field then game is
over so you need to add that logic
second thing you need to do is increase
the game speed
you know in the game whenever you go to
next level the challenge the difficulty
level increases so that's what you're
trying to do here
once you develop your own solution
then you can click on my solution by
clicking on this link but please
try to work on your own first before you
click on this solution
now that your game is ready you want to
convert python file into exe file
exe file is an executable file which
you might have used it for different
programs so this is something you can
give it to your friends
and your friend can just use the exe
and run the game so this completes the
whole
game development cycle when i google
convert python to exe i found this nice
module on
pi pi so just do pip install
this particular module on your computer
to install it so if you do
this it will just install that
particular
module and once it is installed you can
run this command on your command prompt
and it will open a nice user interface
where you specify your file that you
want to convert
into exa so this is the final
file path so i supply that
second option is either you want to
create the whole directory or just
one executable file now you would
probably
prefer this because it just creates one
exe file
so you can do that but right now i'm
having some
python 3.8 incompatibility issue
so for me it is not working as of today
but you just try it it might work for
you so i will just go with one directory
in the additional files i want to
specify add folder
because i want to specify all the
resources the resources has background
music and everything
if you don't do this the it will not
work so this is a very important step
and then you just click on this command
say convert
that to exe so internally
this tool is taking your python file
and generating the binary or the dot exe
file
for you i selected the directory options
so it will create a big directory but if
you choose one file option it will
create just one file for you
once this is done click on open output
folder because that's where your
exe file is so
okay since i created directory it it has
created the whole
directory here okay see this is what i
got
and if you click on this exe now
see my game is playing this is my game
guys
now you can right click this and you can
say send to desktop
and when you do that it will create a
shortcut on desktop so
let me show you so it created this
shortcut and now see
whenever i log into computer i want to
play the game i double click
say it's like just any other program you
see
so now you can take this folder zip it
or there is an option to convert it into
installer as well you can convert it to
installer
and um give it to your friends and you
can be
now proud about yourself because you
build the complete game
you can use these learnings that you did
in
all these videos and maybe make a
different game maybe you can make tic
tac toe
or different type of games so now you
are capable
of building full-fledged game in python
so i hope you like this series if you
did
please uh share this project with your
friends
i have complete source code available
here along with exercise the solution
everything
so all you need is a laptop and internet
and a little bit willpower to learn this
thing
these things are super easy these uh
this project is perfect for even kids
you know if you are in fifth grade
fourth grade
you learn a little bit python from my
videos and then you do this and you will
be able to
build cool games so i hope you liked all
these videos
and thank you very much for watching